schon seit 2015 hat der space ex
gründer/innen maske die idee den mars
bewohnbar zu machen thermonukleare
waffen könnten über den eiskappen der
maßvoll eingesetzt werden um die
atmosphäre des planeten zu erwerben über
twitter hält er uns über seine gedanken
dazu auf dem laufenden demnach könnten
die wasserstoffbombe möglicherweise auch
durch sonnen reflektoren satelliten
ersetzt werden
links zum science fiction die gibt's den
gespannen des heims videos abonniert den
kanal und activity klocke und dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
news so twitterte ihnen masken mitte
august 2009 10 schwach radioaktive
kernfusion explosionen über der
marsatmosphäre könnten den mars also im
besten fall zu einem lebensfreundlichen
planeten verwandeln muss betont dass
diese methode nicht riskant sei und der
mars dadurch keinesfalls radioaktiv
würde
einen tag später ergänzt er dann noch in
einem tweet t shirt zu diese idee von
elon musk ist nicht neu doch hat er sie
damit noch einmal bekräftigt und sogar
entsprechenden t-shirts design auch in
einer amerikanischen late night show
hatte ihnen mass von zwei möglichkeiten
gesprochen den mars bewohnbar zu machen
demnach gibt es eine schnelle und eine
langsame methode den schnellen weg
beschrieb ihnen musk folgendermaßen
schmeiße thermonukleare bomben über die
pole
im klartext ist hier vom sogenannten
terra formen in die rede
durch das andere planeten in bewohnbare
erdähnlichen himmelskörper verwandelt
werden könnten schon 19 84 schlug der
physiker james lovelock treibhausgase in
die atmosphäre zu bringen so genannte
perfluorcarbon pfc hunderte
produktionsanlagen so groß wie autos
ließen dann die mars
oberflächentemperatur innerhalb von 100
jahren um 20 grad steigen
love rocks berechnung zufolge also von
minus 60 grad celsius auf minus 40 grad
celsius das co2 aus dem polen würde in
die atmosphäre übergehen als
treibhausgas würde es für eine weitere
temperatursteigerung sorgen auf etwa
plus 20 grad celsius innerhalb von 6 100
jahren das wasser als würde sich
verflüssigen was die bildung von
mehreren und
zur folge hätte durch einen hohen
atmosphärendruck würde seine verdunstung
verhindert werden innerhalb einiger
jahrhunderte wäre der mars also warm und
feucht relativ perfekte
lebensbedingungen für uns menschen wäre
dann noch einen sauerstoff atmen system
wichtig etwa sowie taucher sie benutzten
noch perfekter wäre es natürlich wenn
sich das co2 in der atmosphäre sogar in
sauerstoff umwandeln ließ eine mögliche
idee algen die viel co2 aushalten
dadurch könnten dann auch pflanzen auf
dem mars gedeihen doch leider ist die
photosynthese der pflanzen zu diesem
zweck nicht wirklich effektiv
schätzungen zufolge würde es eine
million jahre dauern das co2 das maßen
sauerstoff zu verwandeln
würmer und insekten dagegen könnten
schon deutlich früher auf dem mars leben
als wir menschen ihnen muss greift diese
idee also auf und möchte die polkappen
des mars schmelzen lassen umgesetzt
werden könnte das mit wasserstoffbomben
die über den mars polen gezündet werden
müssten
das wasser das in den ice polen des mars
steckt würde dann verdunsten doch nicht
nur wasser auch kohlendioxid würde
freigesetzt werden und einen
treibhauseffekt hervorrufen
denn die treibhausgase würden nicht nur
die mars atmosphäre erwärmt sondern auch
deren dichte erhöhen so dass auf dem
planeten flüssiges wasser existieren
könnte zudem könnten sie astronauten
astronauten auch ohne druck anzug auf
dem roten planeten aufhalten elenas geht
davon aus dass durch die zündung von
thermopal bomben im weltraum nur wenig
schäden entstehen würden doch es gibt
nicht wenige kritiker zum einen ist
wissenschaftlich gar nicht gesichert ob
sein atomwaffen plan auf dem mars
aufgehen würde forschungsteams mit
zweifeln dass es überhaupt genügend co2
auf dem roten planeten gibt um den
gewünschten treibhauseffekt zu
provozieren zudem würde das vorhandene
co2 auch noch aus der atmosphäre ins all
sie kann und so für den plan verloren
gehen und falls der plan aufgehen würde
würde die so entstandene mars atmosphäre
überhaupt bestehen bleiben würde nicht
wieder eine erosion durch den sonnenwind
stattfinden
diese ganzen prozesse sind noch lange
nicht ganz verstanden doch vermutlich
würde die atmosphäre erst einmal für
einige zeit bestehen bleiben
zum anderen spricht auch der sogenannte
atomwaffen
traumvertrag gegen diese idee da
kernwaffen demnach nicht außerhalb der
erdatmosphäre eingesetzt werden dürfen
zudem sind auch die folgen für das klima
auf dem mars nicht abzuschätzen
abgesehen davon ist auch die umsetzung
von mas plan anzuzweifeln
denn wie alleine sollen so viele
kernwaffen zum mars geschafft werden
berechnungen legen nahe dass alle gern
waffen auf dieser welt offener etwa 1 70
der benötigten energie kommen würden um
das pohl trockeneis auf dem mars zu
sublimieren um die drei millionen bomben
sind demnach notwendig und solch eine
hohe anzahl an sprengköpfen muss ja auch
erstmal zum mars gebracht werden um
einige probleme zu umgehen könnten laut
ihnen maske aber auch sonnen reflektor
satelliten eingesetzt werden dazu
schreibt er im august auf twitter nexans
2000 auf solar reflektor satellites
thomas wörz des artikels übersetzt also
so viel wie es könnte sinn machen
tausende von sonnen reflektor satelliten
zu nutzen um den mars mit künstlichen
sonnen zu erwerben die wasserstoffbombe
können also durch satelliten ersetzt
werden fest steht jedenfalls innenmaß
ist davon überzeugt eines tages den mars
zu besiedeln und dabei ist er zusammen
mit seinem team super ehrgeizig und
motiviert an der sache denn geht es nach
innen mascagni lediglich eine autarke
stand auf dem roten planeten das
fortbestehen der menschheit sichern wie
samas früh raus anklicken anschauen und
weltraum wissen von astro comics tv
kostenlos ist es ja abonnieren es lohnt
sich also bis dann bleibt dran